muy bien y es el momento de la revista
de prensa con el rosa pérez además de
rosa buenos días y que tema nos tiene
para empezar buenos dias angela pues si
te parece empezamos por portugal no por
estas elecciones en las que el partido
socialista cosechó más del 40 por ciento
de los votos que se tradujo en una
mayoría absoluta en términos de
diputados si te parece empezamos
comentando el medio público que destaca
los votantes dieron al partido
socialista la mayoría absoluta que costa
pedía y destaca que el primer ministro
tras renovar la legislatura con una
mayoría absoluta puede formar gobierno
sin tener que negociar ni con la
izquierda ni con la derecha y en otro
orden de las cosas el diario de noticias
dice el partido socialista con mayoría
absoluta aplasta al bloque de izquierdas
y al partido comunista crisis de
liderazgo en el partido socialdemócrata
y en el democratacristiano partido
popular pues crisis de liderazgo en la
derecha y dice aconteció lo que ningún
sondeo anticipó nadie
y de otra parte tenemos también noticia
del moscú times que dicen los medios pro
estatales rusos o sobre ucrania rosa
exacto este a medio hace un repaso de lo
que es su actitud a la prensa pero
estatal rosa porque comenta que mientras
a la prensa global está centrada en una
eventual la invasión rusa de ucrania
pues que la prensa estatal rusa ve las
cosas desde un ángulo distinto empieza
por el canal 1 de televisión que
destacaba que sergei lávrov en la duma
decía vemos que nuestros colegas
occidentales están en un estado de
frenesí belicista y que nunca hemos
atacado a nadie somos nosotros los que
siempre hemos sido atacados y todos los
que lo hicieron siempre obtuvieron su
merecido recordemos estas palabras del
ministro de exteriores ruso ante la duma
luego la televisión russia uno tal y
como explica el moscú times no llevaba
como primer titular en prime time la
semana pasada el tema de ucrania sino
que llevaba antes cuestiones del cob o
de las negociaciones comerciales entre
rusia italia y que el presentador
comentó selenski recordemos el
presidente de ucrania trata de calmar
una población asustada pero eeuu sigue
enviando más y más armas por otro lado
la agencia estatal estás dice el
comandante de las fuerzas armadas de
ucrania pronto llegará al donbass para
preparar una posible ofensiva y
ucraniana por otro lado la consumo
lescay a fraude dice dones que ha sido
rodeado las ciber tropas de ucrania y de
la otan y han comenzado una nueva guerra
en el donbass y cierra con la agencia
ria que también habla de un supuesto
plan ucraniano de atacar el donbass con
armas bioquímicas bueno rosa y cortina
de humo en el reino unido the guardian y
the time se les dedican en viñetas a
boris johnson por la crisis del parche
gate que al parecer él ha aprovechado
para hacerlo a un lado con la crisis de
ucrania exactamente las dos viñetas que
destacamos van en esta misma dirección
con esta táctica de boris johnson de
intentar desviar la atención aquí nicola
de jennings está viñetista pues digamos
dibuja boris johnson de camino a la ya
anunciada visita visita del premier
ministro a ucrania y vemos aquí como
deja atrás en esta parte inferior
derecha del dibujo pues hay distintos
problemas internos por un lado este
reporte está informe de la alta
funcionaria su grey sobre el parte y
gate del que pronto seguramente
tendremos más información también vemos
hay un cartel sobre irlanda del norte y
todas bueno la problemática cuando se
cumplen 50 años del bloody sunday y en
este otro el dibujo de the gardian vemos
aquí boris johnson como en actitud de
riña no a vladimir putin y putin que le
responde con sus 100.000 tropas aquí
colocadas en la frontera de rusia con
ucrania es un evento de trabajo esta
excusa utilizada por boris johnson
cuando se les señaló por haber
participado de estas celebraciones en
downing street durante el confinamiento
y cambiando de tema vamos hasta el país
con un reporte de la periodista beatriz
de guillén juárez feminicida en serie
así es este reportaje es sin ser
sensacionalista durísimo angela y pues
habla de distintos casos no solamente de
narrando lo que pasó sino también puedes
conversando con familiares y personas
cercanas de las más de 2300 mujeres que
han sido asesinadas en ciudad juárez
durante las últimas tres décadas o de
las 282 desaparecidas que se han
contabilizado en este mismo periodo de
tiempo por otro lado distintos analistas
de la situación señalan que la violencia
se recrudece ante la llegada de nuevas
fuerzas del crimen organizado y para
resumir un poco las distintas voces que
participan de este texto pues entre
otras cosas señalan y culpan al estado
por no poder hacer justicia en esta en
esta ciudad